When Beijing won the bid to host the 2008
Summer Olympics, China knew it had been handed
a once-in-history opportunity.
What would’ve been a mere sporting event
for 3rd place Paris or 2nd place Toronto,
was more akin to a national graduation ceremony
for China.
As 30,000 fireworks exploded on the opening
day,
As 10,000 performers performed,
And when the Olympic cauldron was finally
lit,
China’s symbolic tassel was turned, and
it ceased being, if only in our minds, just
another developing country.
China was now a global player.
While the Olympics always take on a kind of
performative quality, rarely are the stakes
so high.
After all, a nation only graduates once.
In the seven years leading up to the event,
Beijing underwent both a physical and cultural
transformation.
Its airport received a $1 billion upgrade,
three new subway lines were built, and 23
new roads were laid.
Campaigns were launched to fight against spitting,
smoking, littering, and cutting in line — anything
that might give visitors a negative impression.
In the words of then-Premier Wen Jiabao, the
goal was to depict the country as “democratic,
open, civilized, friendly, and harmonious”.
Humorous as this description may sound today,
it once wasn’t such a ridiculous idea.
Having just joined the World Trade Organization,
and in the context of a thirty-year reform
era led by Deng Xiaoping, when a smiling Jackie
Chan sang “Beijing Welcomes You” in front
of the Great Wall, frankly, one was inclined
to believe him, however cheesy the music video.
China was on its best behavior.
A little bit of wishful thinking was warranted.
A lot has changed since 2008.
Gone are the days of people exchanges, Confucius
Institutes, and liberalization fantasies.
In, are crackdowns, crude insults, explicit
threats, and war games.
Today, it’s awfully hard to believe that
the China who “opened its arms to the world”
— who declared the “whole world” its
friend — is the same country we know now,
just ten short years apart.
A decade ago, to observe that China sought
soft power would’ve seemed humorously banal
— what nation doesn’t?
The record-setting $100 million+ price tag
of the 2008 opening ceremony made very clear
exactly how much it cared what you thought
of it.
2021 China, on the other hand, is liable to
do enough reputational damage on any given
Tuesday to offset that entire era of reputation
building.
In an almost too-Hollywood ending, the lyricist
behind “Beijing Welcomes You” — a song
almost universally loved in China — would
eventually be erased from the Chinese internet
after showing support for Hong Kong protestors.
What happened to make China aggressively and
needlessly burn bridges with the same impressive
vigor it once made friends?
Sponsored by CuriosityStream and Nebula — where
you can watch the bonus video which accompanies
this one.
Around 2019 — long after every last grandma,
Luddite, puppy, and local car dealership finally
gave in and created a Twitter account — the
company found a surprising new source of user
growth: Chinese Diplomats.
Embassies, consulates, politicians, and ambassadors
all suddenly and inexplicably decided to join
the site around the same time — naturally,
raising some eyebrows.
After years of largely ignoring American social
media, what new 280-character insights did
they just have to share with the world?
Not much, it turns out.
Follow one of these accounts and you’d see
a continuous stream of Xi Jinping smiling
at various objects, among other mundane headlines.
Top hashtags used by these accounts included
captivating topics like the #China-Pakistan
Economic Corridor.
Once a year you’d be blessed with a flurry
of posts about #TwoSessions — a reference
to the annual plenary sessions of the National
People's Congress.
Clearly, the Communist Party was still a long
way from mastering the art of subtweeting.
Interspersed with these glorified press releases,
however, was, every once in a while, something
very different.
The Chinese embassy in Brazil accused its
president of having a “mental virus”,
Another diplomat addressed the Prime Minister
of Canada as “boy” and called him a “spendthrift”.
These are two of the more tame examples.
Members of the Chinese Foreign Ministry have
hurled such bizarre insults as “crazed hyena”,
“fatso”, and “running dog” — and
at citizens of their host countries, no less.
They’ve promoted conspiracy theories, spread
offensive images, and mocked India’s deadly
crisis — all in an official capacity.
And in case anyone thought these were just
rogue agents, China stamped its official seal
of approval on this behavior in March, when
it held talks with the U.S. in Alaska.
There, the most senior Chinese diplomat, who
reports directly to Xi Jinping, pulled no
punches, saying “The US is not qualified
to speak to China from a position of strength.”
This style of communication has worked about
as well as you’d expect — which is to
say, very, very poorly.
The share of Americans who view China unfavorably
reached the highest level on record two years
ago, and has only continued rising at the
same pace since.
While this trend may not surprise you, take
a second to appreciate just how overwhelming
this sentiment is.
For context, the shift in opinion which has
taken place in the last three years is roughly
equivalent to that in the aftermath of the
1989 Tiananmen Square massacre.
China is now the country Americans view most
negatively — with the exception of only
Iran and North Korea.
That means Americans view it less favorably
than Russia, Cuba, Iraq, or Afghanistan.
In an unbelievably polarized era, the Communist
Party has truly managed to do the incredible:
unite Democrats and Republicans.
China is one of the few truly bipartisan issues
in America.
A majority of both parties — 77% of conservatives,
54% of liberals, and 56% of moderates, see
its economic rise as a “critical threat”.
But don’t think this is unique to the U.S.
Unfavorable views of China are also at their
all-time high in Australia, the UK, Germany,
the Netherlands, Sweden, South Korea, Spain,
and Canada.
One of the few countries not to experience
this trend is Japan… but only because it
had already maxed out.
Now, it would be both unfair and misleading
to ignore the ways in which the U.S. and other
countries are also responsible for this shift
— in ways both legitimate and not.
Creating a common, foreign enemy and exploiting
fears of imagined rivals, is, without a doubt,
a common political strategy for gaining domestic
support.
Innocent Chinese and Asian-Americans have
been caught in the crossfire, used as pawns,
and accused only of their race.
But however much foreign politicians may be
predisposed to portray China as an enemy,
no government has done more to tarnish its
reputation than China itself.
With ƒcrackdown, sanction, or inflammatory
remark, China makes it harder and harder for
foreign countries to associate with it.
Its hostility has brought its southeast Asian
neighbors closer together, made Australia
wary of its influence, and single-handedly
thwarted its investment deal with the European
Union.
Whenever there remains some room for giving
it the benefit of the doubt, China is incredibly
quick to eliminate any ambiguity.
When Huawei tried to prove its independence
from Chinese authorities, for instance, those
very authorities were the first to defend
the company.
In its ongoing crackdown against Jack Ma,
it’s made perfectly clear nobody is above
the party.
The big question, then, is why?
Why are individual diplomats, all the way
up to the highest ranks of power, absolutely
intent on wilfully destroying China’s reputation?
What does it get out of all this?
To answer this question, we necessarily have
to leave the realm of raw facts and enter
that of speculation.
We’ve seen what is — now we try our best
to explain it.
The most common theory goes something like
this:
The difference between 2008 and 2018 China
is that today it’s in a position of strength.
China can afford to be confident and assertive
because a) it’s a large, powerful, and important
country, and b) it genuinely believes in the
decline of its rival, the United States.
Its diplomatic approach may be... brash, but
only because it otherwise wouldn’t be taken
seriously.
By setting the precedent that China will retaliate
against even the slightest perceived aggression,
smaller, less powerful countries are deterred
from acting out.
The problem with this line of thinking is
that strong, powerful nations generally don’t
go around needlessly destroying their own
reputations.
China’s method of “asserting” itself
— calling people “thugs” and “hyenas”
— is just plain cartoonish.
It belongs in Hollywood — and that’s no
coincidence.
The term used to describe this behavior is
“Wolf Warrior Diplomacy” — a reference
to a hyper-patriotic, Rambo-style Chinese
military film franchise.
The second theory is that its diplomats are,
in essence, acting — though, the movie only
makes sense in Chinese.
People or countries as confident as China
are always insecure.
Does the kid on the playground who constantly
feels the need to puff up his chest and warn
you how tough he is, seem confident?
Seasoned diplomats, of course, are not 11-year
olds on the playground.
They’re trained professionals with careers
at stake, which suggests their colorful language
serves a real purpose.
The reason the smallest dog barks the loudest
is not just to compensate for its relative
size, but also, to convince itself.
The audience for the PG-13 rated movie Chinese
diplomats star in every time they tweet an
angry insult is not the world, but rather,
the Chinese public, who respond to these attacks
just as positively as the rest of the world
does negatively.
In response to China’s adversarial tone
in the Alaska talks, for instance, the Chinese
internet was flooded with support for the
diplomats, who were “finally standing up
for the country”.
It works.
The language has become more and more inflammatory
because it’s expressly designed to create
conflict.
The more offended the foreign public, the
more hatred is hurled back at China, which,
in turn, puts the Chinese public on the defensive.
It’s a simple trade — lose support abroad,
in exchange for stoking nationalism, and thus
support, at home.
But, is it really worth it?, you may, quite
reasonably, wonder.
Credibility is among the most valuable resources
a nation can behold, and rebuilding it takes
years, if not decades.
By so thoroughly burning every last bridge,
China has implicitly committed to its aggressive
tactics for years to come.
With the costs this high, the only world in
which this trade would be worthwhile is if
its leaders were that worried about the outlook
at home.
They may have good reason.
First, its population is rapidly aging.
The past few decades of widespread improvements
to quality of life have coincided with a glut
of productive workers — those aged roughly
30-64.
In the next few decades, these producers will
retire at a staggering rate, and the One-Child
Policy will have left too few people to replace
them.
Intense nationalism and the difficulty of
learning the Chinese language, among other
things, will prevent immigrants from filling
in these gaps in any meaningful way.
Second, it’s so far failed the transition
to consumption-led growth.
Instead, nearly a third of its economy relies
on an unsustainable real estate bubble.
The vast majority of new purchases are of
2nd or even 3rd homes, and prices across the
country reflect a highly speculative market.
Because local governments rely on land sales
for their survival, they have no choice but
to encourage wasteful spending merely to balance
the budget.
Third, a combination of mismanagement, climate
change, and geographic luck have left China
with a severe water shortage.
In the past two decades, 28,000 of its rivers
have dried up, the majority of the rest are
severely polluted, and what remains is only
a drop in the bucket.
The North China plain, one of the country’s
most populous regions, faces a Saudi-Arabia-level
crisis, minus the oil riches which enable
desalination.
What sets these challenges apart is not their
severity or even scale,
Every country faces obstacles to its development,
and more than three videos could be devoted
to many of them.
Neither demographics, housing, nor water problems
are unique to China.
In fact, in each case there exists, if not
a solution, at least a way to mitigate the
effects.
China could have ended the One-Child Policy
decades earlier,
It could accept the short-term losses necessary
to shift its dependence from real estate,
and market-based pricing reform would reduce
its wasteful use of water.
No, what makes China unique is that it doesn’t
believe it can admit the extent of these problems,
and therefore can’t adequately address them.
In the eyes of the Chinese government, a $100
billion engineering project to physically
move water halfway across the country is easy,
while simply raising water prices is unthinkable.
The Communist Party has now held power for
as long as the Soviet Union existed, and it’s
acutely aware of how environmental protests
contributed to the downfall of its counterpart.
Raising the price of water even slightly would
cause a material change in quality of life
for millions of poor Chinese, not to mention
the effect it would have on economic growth.
Ecological or pricing concerns may not intuitively
rise to the level of national security, but
in the words of one Canadian researcher, they
do “Present a unifying focal point for dissent
that crosses geographic, cultural, socioeconomic,
and political lines”.
While China may project confidence in press
conferences, its actions tell a very different
story.
Its military budget receives considerable
attention, but you might be surprised to hear
it actually spends more on domestic security.
Provoking nationalism is like training an
attack dog — Sure, you gain a powerful weapon
to use against your real or perceived enemies,
but it's a rather blunt weapon.
The more a dog is wound up, the stronger its
bite will be when the time comes to fend off
an attacker, but also the more unstable it
becomes, and the more the owner should be
worried about losing control.
Nationalism creates immense pressure for the
government to act tough, increasing the cost
of restraint.
The one thing it cannot afford to do is be
perceived as weak or indecisive.
Because if it does, it risks becoming the
dog, or rather, wolf’s, next victim.
Next year Beijing will once again host the
Olympics, but this time, it won’t be so
welcoming.
If 2008 was the culmination of three decades
of reform and optimism, 2022 is shaping up
to be just as consequential.
What are the odds of a boycott?
And what will the games signify this time?
Watch the bonus video which accompanies this
one on Nebula — the streaming site I helped
create along with your other favorite educational
YouTube channels.
Roughly every other PolyMatter video has bonus
or extended content available on Nebula.
The first part of this series, for example,
has a section on why the U.S. doesn’t have
the same demographic challenges as China,
there’s one about how Singapore convinced
its population to drink pee, one on the future
of food, and more.
Nebula also has entirely exclusive Originals,
like Wendover Production’s documentary about
Alaska, Lowspecgamer’s podcast “Genesis”,
and Tom Scott’s game show “Money”.
We’ve partnered with CuriosityStream — home
to great documentaries on technology, history,
and science — like this one about why China
has one last remaining steam train — so
that you can get it and Nebula for less than
$15 a year.
Sign up with the link in the description and
watch the bonus video over on Nebula.